es el nombre de nuestra tierra sagrada
en guaraní marae significa Tierra sin
mal los indígenas de la aldea mata verde
bonita en el estado de Río de Janeiro
protestan contra la construcción de un
Macro complejo turístico
yo les ordené que parasen están
masacrando a mi pueblo ahora por la
mañana cortaron estos árboles dos tres
Cuántos árboles cortaron aquí 40
familias viven en esta restinga
protegida por Su riqueza medioambiental
estamos en maricá el municipio que
acumula el mayor crecimiento del pib de
Brasil gracias a los royalties del
petróleo
pero esta riqueza no llega a la
población indígena que mal vive en casas
de barro
esta paja está desapareciendo aquí de
nuestra región por eso nuestras casas
Están en malas condiciones
estos guaraníes fueron realojados aquí
hace una década tras ser expulsados de
una región vecina por la especulación
edilicia nunca recibieron los títulos de
propiedad de las tierras no se oponen a
la construcción de un Resort de lujo
pero en contrapartida exigen al
ayuntamiento que invierta en saneamiento
y en salud
esta aldea guaraní atrapada entre los
rascacielos de San Pablo es el símbolo
de la resistencia de los indígenas ante
el avance de la presión urbanística Aquí
viven 700 personas repartidas en seis
aldeas en su momento fue la región
indígena demarcada más pequeña del país
posee tan solo 1,73 hectáreas ya tuvimos
niños atropellados aquí por causa de la
división que los no indígenas hicieron
en nuestra aldea para poder llegar al
centro de Sao Paulo
estos indígenas urbanos son
discriminados por los blancos de la
ciudad y también por los nativos de las
reservas que los critican por haber
perdido sus tradiciones y su lengua
original